Brady. And I have just been looking at some photos from the 1930s
archive of Nottingham.
These are labs that were the real state of the art.
The building had just been built as far as I knew that these photos here
of research students,
we knew that at least one of them called Wagstaff who's here subsequently
10 years later died in the second world war.
He was on a bomber which disappeared and never returned behind these
photos. There are very real personal stories.
There are some quite strange things. People smoking pipes,
some of you might not even know what a pipe is.
Wooden thing for smoking tobacco. They're not wearing safety glasses,
the loads of chemicals everywhere. It's pretty untidy.
They know women, I suppose.
That's not so surprising because even when I was a student,
there weren't many women chemists.
These labs were brand new when the photo had been taken.
And we're in a really lucky position that I can show you some
labs that are also brand new. They were opened two weeks ago.
So let's go upstairs and see what differences we can spot.
Before we go up. I should show you my tie,
special tie with test tubes and things on it. What's really special.
Is that here,
Tim gamble set it on fire with white phosphorus in the middle of a lecture.
Before we go, let me stress. This is a teaching lab.
It's for science, technology, engineering and maths. They,
what the mathematicians will do in this lab. I'm not sure.
So the first thing you noticed, everything's weight,
the benches await the lab coats await.
Whereas you can see in the photo that the benches are dark and I think they
don't lab coats are a darkish color.
The next thing you've noticed is it's enormous compared
to this lab in the photo, there are many more students.
This is partly because there are many more students in universities than they
were in the 1930s. There are lots more fume cupboards in the photo.
There's perhaps one. And you can see here that fume cup is everywhere.
The other thing that's really funny is that some of the film
cupboards have transparent backs. So if we go round here,
you can see the students working away
without even needing to wear safety glasses.
And at the same time
we frightened them away.
It's good for them because if I want to demonstrate something,
they can stand around this side and watch what I'm doing great is really excited
because he can imagine videoing Neil from a completely different
angle,
seeing what he's really thinking when he doesn't speak.
So we can walk along this corridor to get to the middle
part of the lab. And again, you'll see the quite big differences.
One of the things you'll see immediately is that the people who teaching,
wearing colored lab coats like me so that the students can immediately
see who can help them. We have red coats,
our inorganic chemists,
and the green ones over there are the organic chemists.
So that's also an innovation mixing up organic chemists and then
organic chemists together.
It makes the lab much more flexible.
It means you don't need to have all the equipment duplicated.
One of the things that hasn't changed very much from this photo is the sink.
You can see here. There's still a sink with relatively seamless taps.
But the difference is that the sink is now made that a plastic rather
than porcelain or China,
so that if you drop some glassware in there, it doesn't break.
You see? So you don't have to pay for it.
But students nowadays don't have to pay for their glassware. Anyway,
in the old days,
some students had to finish their course early because they couldn't pay for the
glassware that they were breaking.
Dreadful.
There's one difference from really quite recent labs.
There are lots and lots of fire extinguishers.
When I was teaching in the lab on the floor below a student,
set fire to the bench,
and it took me a long time to find the fire extinguisher.
And by then the bench was really blazing away.
And once we put it out for years, I saw this child Mark.
Every time I went into the lab,
the most exciting thing about this lab is something which you might not have
noticed. This bench here,
which has taps is fixed just like the benches in the old
labs,
which we'll fix down and had to stay there for years and years and years.
But all the other benches that you can see in both
directions are on wheels. And so if we suddenly decide,
we'd like to change the way we teach this particular class in an
afternoon, we can completely change the configuration of the lab,
move the benches around, move the electrical power around.
And so on the key to the flexibility are these sort of the
elephant trunks,
because what these are doing are they contain the electrical power to the
benches, the internet connections.
And of course the pipes for the pipe,
nitrogen and compressed air that you have on the benches
and the water.
Apart from the basins where you wash your hands and some glass where all
the water is in the fume cupboards.
I haven't mentioned gas. We all think of Bunsen burners in labs.
There's no guests in this lab. So how do they heat things up?
The answer is with a guest like this,
I had to be taught how to use it a few minutes ago, you clip it down.
[Inaudible].
And the flavor comes out the door of the few.
It is automated, like Lyft, you press the button.
[Inaudible].
One of the things that I thought was interesting is that when a bubble catches
fire, the burning gas continues to move up
almost the same shape as the bubble.